[Applaudissements]
prendre les grands moyens pour mieux se
protéger contre la coved 19
c'est ce que le chirurgien
maxillo-facial rhône et qui ici a fait
en confectionnant dans son garage une
cagoule de protection intégrale voulait
trouver une pièce d'équipement qui
allait remplacer 2,95 la lumière la
visière et châteaux chirurgicale dans
quelque chose qui englobe complètement
le visage travailler dans la bouche de
ces patients exposé le docteur qu'ici au
virus
le risque de contracter la maladie et de
la transmettre à son garçon asthmatiques
les frais les protéger et puis je
voulais pas non plus abandonné mes
collègues de travail en une fin de
semaine
le chirurgien a fabriqué un échantillon
assemblée avec des matériaux trouvés en
quincaillerie dr qui ici a fait appel à
ccm fabricant de produits de beauté
qu'il qualifie d' experts en couture de
vêtements spécialisés
on a semblé une petite équipe il y avait
rencontré à la lysine
saint-jean-sur-richelieu
puis après une heure on a déjà construit
pour être efficace il faut maintenir une
pression constante dans la cagoule
elle pose dans une machine qui filtre
l'air avec des filtres hepa et puis on a
de l'air très propre qui gonfle notre
cas google ça allait pousser un peu les
particules qui pourraient éventuellement
pénétrer
si jamais
l'entrée à l'intérieur du casque des
tests effectués en laboratoire ont
démontré que la cagole offre une
protection dix fois supérieur au masque
n95 si santé canada approuve la cagoule
ccm pourra en produire jusqu'à 150 par
jour qu'elle vendra au prix coûtant une
quinzaine de dollars
revenons un peu espoir qu'on est capable
de tout et les solutions sis au québec
et les mettre en application de façon la
pile comme quoi l'ingéniosité ne prend
pas de pause en temps de crise ici
valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal